IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
TURNING INTO AN ABSOLUTE CIRCUS.
AND CNN IS BEING BRUTALLY MOCKED
FOR MAKING IT EVEN WORSE.
CNN LOSING EVEN MORE CREDIBILITY
AND TURNING IT INTO A GAME SHOW
NETWORK BY REVEALING THE
UPCOMING DEBATE LINEUPS LIKE
THIS.
>> WE WANT TO RANDOMLY DRAW
CANDIDATES.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE THEM AND
MIX THEM UP SO THAT WE CAN THEN
DRAW FROM A CANDIDATE BOX.
>> ANOTHER SHUFFLE.
MIX THEM UP.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE THESE A
GOOD MIX.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THEM A GOOD
SHUFFLE.
>> PLACED THEM INTO THE DEBATES
BOX.
>> WE HAVE MULTIPLE CAMERA
VIEWS.
>> YOU CAN WATCH THE CAMERA
ABOVE ME OVERHEAD.
>> I WILL NOT LOOK INTO THE BOX,
BUT YOU CAN WITH THE OVERHEAD
CAMERA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: TOUGH TO WATCH.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
CANDIDATES IT IS BROKEN INTO TWO
NIGHTS.
FACING OFF ON NIGHT ONE,
BERNIE SANDERS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN, BATTLING TO
SEE WHO IS THE BIGGEST
SOCIALIST.
AND GREG AND I ARE PARTICULARLY
HAPPY ABOUT THIS.
MARION WILLIAMSON WILL JOIN THEM
ON STAGE TO SPREAD THE LOVE.
AND THE SECOND NIGHT FEATURES A
REMATCH BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
WE WILL SEE IF SLEEPY JOE WILL
ACTUALLY FIGHT BACK THIS TIME.
GREG, I HAVE NOT SEEN IT BECAUSE
I DO NOT WATCH CNN UNTIL THEN, I
THINK THEY MADE IT LESS
INTERESTING.
>> Greg: IT IS AMAZING.
THE SERIOUS MUSIC MADE IT
FUNNIER.
CNN IS THE CARNIVAL NEWS
NETWORK.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE CLOWNS,
NOW THEY HAVE THE ATTRACTION.
THEY NEED TO ADD A DUNK TANK,
PIE EATING CONTEST, A RING TOSS
WHERE JOHN LENNON CAN TOSS RINGS
ON CHRIS COMEAU'S HEAD.
I FEEL LIKE I'M BEING TOO MEAN
OR NOT MEAN ENOUGH.
CNN IS THE NETWORK WITHOUT
RIGHT.
BECAUSE CLOSE FRIENDS TELL YOU
WHEN YOU ARE MAKING A FOOL OUT
OF YOURSELF.
HEY, THAT IS AN OBVIOUS TOUPEE,
CHRIS, YOU ARE NOT FUNNY.
PEOPLE WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU
HAVE WISED IT DOWN OR YOU NEED
MOUTHWASH, BUT NOBODY IS TELLING
CNN THAT THEY LOOK LIKE IDIOTS
WHEN THEY DO THIS STUFF.
>> Jesse: MSNBC SHOULD BE LIKE
HEY, GUYS, YOU HAVE SOME
CHATTER.
>> Greg: KNOCK ON THE DOOR.
>> Jesse: LISA, WHAT WAS THAT
STRATEGY?
JUST TRYING TO GRAB RATINGS OR
SHOW TRANSPARENCY?
>> Lisa: PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
OF BOTH, BUT PROBABLY RATINGS,
AND THE SPECIAL WAS CALLED THE
DRAW.
I READ "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WRITE UP ABOUT IT THAT AN EIGHT
PERSON PANEL WAS ANALYZING EVERY
MOVE THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
YOU HAD MULTIPLE PEOPLE PULLING
THE CARDS AND FIGURING OUT WHICH
CANDIDATE WOULD BE ON WHAT
NIGHT, SO ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
BUT WHAT I AM INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT FOR THE DEBATE IS HOW
BADLY DIMINISHED BIDEN AND ERNIE
ARE BY WHO THEY ARE ON THE STAGE
WITH.
BECAUSE KAMALA HARRIS DID SOME
MAJOR DAMAGE TO JOE BIDEN.
AND THEN IF YOU HAVE BERNIE ON
THE STAGE WITH ELIZABETH WARREN,
SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE EXACT SAME
POLICY DECISIONS BUT HIS YOUNGER
AND MORE INTERESTING, YOU CAN
SEE HOW THAT COULD HURT THEM
SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> Jesse: THERE WAS A RACIAL
ANGLE TO THE WHOLE MESS AND ONE
OF THE CNN ANALYST COMMENTED ON
IT.
LET'S WATCH IT AND JUAN CAN
RESPOND.
>> IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT IN
THE MOST DIVERSE FIELD THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS EVER HAD,
ALL OF THE FIRST NIGHTS ARE
WHITE CANDIDATES, AND THE
DIVERSITY IS IN THE SECOND NIGH
NIGHT.
AND RACE HAS BEEN A FRONT AND
CENTER ISSUE IN AMERICA THIS
WEEK.
IT HAS BEEN IN THE CAMPAIGN.
IT IS AN ISSUE THAT IS COURSING
THROUGH THIS DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT, JUAN?
>> Lisa: DOES THAT MEAN CNN IS
RACIST?
>> Juan: YOU GUYS SEE RACE AND
EVERYTHING.
[GROUP REACTION]
>> Jesse: SOMEBODY QUOTE THAT,
CLICK THAT RIGHT THERE.
>> Juan: ALL THAT CNN DID,
THAT YOU HAVE RIGHTLY MOCK THEM
FOR, IT WAS A TRANSPARENT
OPERATION.
YOU CAN SEE WHAT WAS GOING ON,
THERE WAS NO BIAS.
WHAT KIND OF CRITICISM OR
CRITIQUE IS THAT OF THE OWN
NETWORK?
TO ME IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT THE
REAL NEWS HERE IS AS LISA WAS
SAYING, YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
KAMALA HARRIS ONCE AGAIN UP
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
SO IT WILL BE THE REDO IN
DETROIT.
AND YOU WILL WANT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS.
HE WAS NOT PREPARED LAST TIME,
LET'S SEE IF HE IS THIS TIME.
HE WILL ALSO HAVE CORY BOOKER ON
THAT BASIS, AND HE HAS BEEN FAR
MORE CRITICAL OF JOE BIDEN FOR
SAYING, NOT ABOUT BUSTING, BUT
FOR SAYING THAT HE CAN CROSS THE
PARTISAN LINE, AND PROVE THAT HE
CAN DO BUSINESS WITH SEGREGATION
IN THE PAST.
GUESS WHAT CORY BOOKER DID NOT
BENEFIT WHEN KAMALA HARRIS WENT
UP IN THE POLL?
SO NOW HE SEES THIS AS HIS
OPPORTUNITY THAT IT WILL BE LIKE
A MOVEMENT AROUND JOE BIDEN.
BY THE WAY, THE POLLS CAME OUT
TODAY, AND AGAIN, BIDEN IS UP.
CLOSE TO 9 ON EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: BUT MARY IS COMING ON
STRONG.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP THE POLLS THAT JUST
CAME ON, BECAUSE TRUMP IS UP
38 PERCENT IN THE NEWS POLL, I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT.
BUT MOVING ON, EMILY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THE SPECTACLE?
>> Emily: I DID IN MY HEAD
WINNERS AND LOSERS, AND THE ONLY
WINNER THAT I SAW IT WAS
KAMALA HARRIS, CNN IS A TOTAL
LOSER BY THAT DEBACLE, YOU SAID
THAT THEY ARE BEING RIGHTLY MOC
MOCK.
BERNIE SANDERS AND ELIZABETH
LOST THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
CHALLENGE BIDEN.
AND THEN BIDEN, I PUT THEM IN
THE LOSER CATEGORY, BECAUSE HE
IS GOING AGAINST KAMALA HARRIS
AND ALSO CORY BOOKER.
HE WILL BE LOOKING AT DOUBLE
PASS BASED ON THE RACIAL RECORD,
IT WOULD NOT MOVE A SYNONYM FOR
HIM TO DEFEND HIS RECORD BY NOT
GOING THERE.
IT WILL BE DEATH BY 1,000 TIMES.
WHAT HE SHOULD DO IS I AM NOT
HERE TO LITIGATE THE PAST, I'M
ON THE STAGE TO TALK ABOUT NOW,
STARTING THE MAN IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
THAT IS A BETTER STRATEGY, FOR
HIM VERSUS KAMALA HARRIS, IT IS
EITHER EARLY '70s OR 1976 WHEN
THE RAIDERS CAME BACK AND BEAT
THEM.
>> Jesse: SPORTS ANALOGY, , AND
IS NOT EVEN HERE.
>> Juan: THE FIRST NIGHT IS
REALLY INTERESTING TO ME.
>> Greg: BECAUSE OF MARIANNE!
SHE IS IN FRONT, JUAN, SHE
JUMPED IN FRONT OF CORY,
KIERSTEN, AND SOME OF THE ELLS.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I'M TELLING YOU, SHE IS THE
TRUMP, JUAN.
WE SHOULD PUT A BET ON IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> Juan: YOU THINK SHE WILL BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> Greg: SHE IS A WILD CARD.
I'M COUNTING ON HER GETTING THE
NOMINATION.
>> Juan: YOU WILL RACK YOUR
VOTING --
>> Greg: I WAS WRONG ON TRUMP
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
IT WILL HIT ME HARD, JUAN.
>> Juan: I AM INTERESTED IN
BERNIE SANDERS VERSUS
ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THAT
THEY WILL CLASH?
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A RERUN, BUT
WARREN HAS NEW IDEAS, BUT IT IS
THE SAME MUSIC.
AND THE QUESTION IS, IS THERE
MORE BENEFIT GOING AFTER EACH
OTHER OR TEAMING UP AND SAYING
BAD JOE BIDEN, HE IS A PROBLEM
AND THE OLD STUFF AND WE ARE THE
NEW --
>> OR FOCUS ON TRUMP THE WHOLE
TIME?
>> Juan: THE OTHER LANE HERE
IS CLO BASHAR AND BENNETT.
>> Jesse: THERE IS A LIEN THEY
ARE?
>> Greg: IT IS A 12 ITEMS OR
LESS LANE.
>> Juan: AND IS PETE BUTTIGIEG
SHOW THAT HE BELONGS?
>> Jesse: HE HAS RAISED A LOT
OF MONEY.
>> Greg: FORGET THE
CANDIDATES.
>> Jesse: I FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE AN IDENTITY CRISIS.
ARE THEY THE SERIOUS NEWS
NETWORK, OR ARE THEY THE NETWORK
ON NEW YEARS AND EVERYBODY GETS
DRUNK, WHO ARE THEY?
>> Greg: IT IS AN INTERESTING
THING THAT HAS HAPPENED TO THEM,
BECAUSE THEY REFUSED TO LABEL
WHETHER THEY ARE NEWS OR
COMMENTARY.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT WE HAVE
OPINIONS AND WE ARE NOT
REPORTERS, YOU KNOW, AT LEAST WE
ARE SPOUTING OFF OPINIONS.
WHEN YOU TURN ON CNN, YOU HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT YOU WILL GET, YOU
HAVE A GUY REPORTING SOMETHING
AND THEN HIS OPINION IN THE SAME
BREATH AND THEN GET IT WRONG OR
RIGHT, BUT YOU CANNOT TELL, IT
IS DISHONEST, AND I THINK THAT
THEY ARE IN A IDENTITY CRISIS,
BECAUSE THEY USED TO BE
SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE DONE LENIN
THROWING DRINK AFTER DRINK BACK
ON NEW YEAR'S AND NOW HE IS THE
DEBATE MONITOR.
>> DON'T BLAME HIM FOR DRINKING.
>> Lisa: MSNBC USED RACHEL
MADDOW, AND NOW YOU HAVE DON
LEMON WHO IS ESSENTIALLY AN
OPINION HOST AS YOU POINTED OUT
BEING USED IN CNN, CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF FOX DID SOMETHING
SIMILAR?